go [ __ ] their burger roll up a leopa
give me a nice brioche bun hey Ron I'm
Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen moving forward
I'm going to try to enunciate the put in
my name because a lot of you guys have
pointed out that it sounds like shart
and nobody wants to be called a shart
just saying okay so in today's what a in
a day youtuber review we are gonna be
talking about Sara's day so I was
watching a bunch of her videos in
preparation for this video and let me
tell ya I kind of um I'm obsessed with
Sara I think she's a sweetheart she's
her videos are hilarious
and she's got great energy I just feel
like I have more energy when I watch her
so Sara talks about starting her channel
as a way to combat her hormonal acne and
has since grown her channel all about
nutrition health beauty and fitness she
also has discussed actually having gone
vegan for six months and raw vegan for
three months but she stopped because it
really did not feel good for her body
and she felt sick all the time and it
was really impacting her athletic
performance Sara now talks about being a
lot more into intuitive eating and
listening to her body which of course
you guys know I love so let's do this
please cancel
I love this girl she's super cute to
watch and her dog is so cute and the dog
seemed is a B so we are totally off to a
really good start here
but let's kick things off because it's
7:00 a.m. and we got a drink our lemon
water my lemon water routine just makes
me feel so much more fresh and
revitalized in the morning flushing
toxins out of your body and just
starting your day on a good note and I
feel like lemon water in the morning it
just puts you in like a healthy mindset
okay so let's talk about lemon water
first of all water of any kind is
awesome it's amazing very hydrating but
as for the claims that it helps to like
flush out toxins kind of Balch kind of
true but countable it's not the lemon in
the water if that's doing it if you have
a working liver and kidneys and you can
go to the bathroom your your cleansing
folks you're gonna flush those toxins
right out so if you want to refresher on
how to cleanse a detox the natural way
you can check that out right here what I
do agree with is Sarah statement that it
helps to kind of like set you up with a
healthy mindset for the day
I could have agree I find that like when
I have a really good health healthy
balanced breakfast and I like feel
satisfied on
I like continue that trend for the rest
of the day versus when I'm like in a
really rushed state and I forget to eat
breakfast and then I get so ravenous by
lunchtime I find it's really hard for me
to eat intuitively and listen to my body
so I agree if that's kind of what's
gonna kick you off on a on a good note
that may all means like do you a water
is great you want to hydrate you want to
hydrate all day long
pre-workout I try to get through at
least one of these a day I used to drink
four liters of water a day I know it
crazy but I'm just not good anymore
today I did a morning gym session and I
just wanted a little something in my
stomach before I started training
usually it's a banana or a protein bowl
but today I was just vibing an organic
red apple that's what I weigh so first
of all just want to say you're not good
or bad for not drinking four liters of
water just so everyone's clear on that
lady but second of all love the Apple
vibing everyone loves a good apple easy
accessible grab and go awesome sorts of
source of carbohydrates and antioxidants
and fiber so I love that I also love
that she's just kind of like listening
to her body and her body says this I
don't want to a smoothie ball I just
want an apple so love it okay
post-workout slash breakfast it's going
to be a smoothie you guys know I don't
care about calories I don't trust macros
or anything like that but I'm just aware
of my nutrition and food choices I'm
using my favorite fruit in the whole
world a whole banana a couple of
spoonfuls of coconut yogurt add my
healthy source of fat this one's
actually lemon flavored to me only thing
I had in the fridge and surprisingly it
was like really delicious
in this combo now I'm to my supplements
for my source of protein I'm using
Tripucka
Lee protein in chocolate and then my
added superfoods and maca powder and
curry powder I started using maca powder
a few years ago and I feel like it's
really good at keeping my skin clear and
kamahele are used for the added immune
boosting properties in vitamin C okay I
never usually do this but I decided to
add some cacao nib into the mix just put
some deck and texture and it was
actually so good so I'm gonna keep love
it finally a smoothie that is of like
reasonable size and doesn't fill an
entire family sized blender so well done
well done Sarah but also there's a lot
to love here you know it's got fiber
it's got protein energizing
carbohydrates omega-3s and healthy fats
YUM II I also love as a post-workout
snack that of course it's great for
feeding those hungry muscles and
replenishing the glycogen stores that
might have gotten used up as for the
supplements there's very little good
research to suggest that maca powder can
improve our skin like we're talking like
a small rat study however maca is rich
in polyphenols antioxidants so it is a
really great little way to to boost
things up in your smoothie if you're not
getting enough from fruits and
vegetables in the day
as for the camu powder it's actually
made up of ground-up sour berries so
it's really really really rich in
vitamin C so advocates claim that it's
really good for immune health
however Sarah is probably getting like a
ton of fruits and vegetables and lots of
vitamin C in our day but you're just
gonna pee out in excess so it's probably
obsolete is it gonna hurt no it's just
kind of an expensive supplement that
probably isn't necessary for most people
with balanced diets
you've watched any of my other what I
eat in the days or just my blogs you'll
know that I'm a serious snack are you
guys also know I'm obsessed with rigid
nut mix and protein balls hence why I
made my own so right now I just kind of
like pick between the two and unlimited
supply in my kitchen so I'm trying to
stick to one a day so today I had that
just to tie me over from my smoothie
until lunchtime so you guys know I love
little kind of protein balls or power
ball's what are you gonna call them I've
got a lot of great recipes for them on
my blog so we'll leave some links below
if you want to check out some of mine
but I took a look at the ingredients in
Sarah's protein balls and they look
great it's very simple things like
cashew butter coconut dates coconut oil
coconut sugar maca cacao salt water very
simple ingredient list basically how I
would make them at home so that's great
I would love to try these and they're
great they're great source of fiber and
protein and good fats and they are so
really really really well balanced snack
this is my super simple delicious tuna
salad nourish Bowl kind of thing Oh busy
gal if I can prepare one thing now
that's going to tie me over for lunch
and you know that's like a win-win
situation a lot of the time I have
pretty sweet potato and pumpkin in the
fridge however today I realized I don't
have any I'm going to prepare this for
lunch now but I'm gonna make extra so I
have it fit in there as well you want
one sweet potato for lunch cook for and
then you're done for like two days
depending how often you have it that's
usually our source of carbohydrate
potatoes pumpkin chickpeas buckwheat we
love all that kind of stuff so first of
all I got freaked out their shoes
holding the knife like in the most
Awkward weird way possible and it just
made me a little anxious but I love that
she's giving some fun little batch
cooking hacks and tips I find that I'm
doing so much more batch cooking these
days now that I'm a mom and it really
does help people get healthy food on the
table fast and
bunch of baby spinach and then comes my
delicious vegan cheesy salad dressing
apple cider vinegar some health tahini I
think I did like a whole tablespoon a
dash of flaxseed oil a crack of pink
salt a squeeze of lemon and then massage
it all together so not only it is going
to combine all the ingredients but it
actually aids digestion like I said just
adding whatever vegetables I had in the
fridge today it was some snow peas and
some butter and then obviously my added
pumpkin and sweet potato now on to my
source of protein you guys know I'm a
coffee snob
so let's I put the dressing I think it
looks super tasty we've got like what's
a healthy fats from the tahini Omega
threes from the flax oil so that's great
as for the idea of like massaging your
greens for digestion we usually see this
with really tough tough greens like kale
and it helps to kind of break up those
really tough fibers to aid in digestion
however with a really delicate green
like spinach I don't know from like just
like a culinary point of view I just
feel like it would get soggy it's so so
fast and most people don't have a
challenge with something delicate like a
baby spinach leaf but I guess if you
have a really delicate gut
maybe it's breaking them up and kind of
like massaging it might help a little
bit might just like break up that
cellulose structure and reduce the
bloating give it a try if it works for
you great but I don't know I would just
be worried about things getting soggy
really fast I'm not hungry
I'll just use one but you guys might eat
a lot of food I have a really fast
metabolism so I usually add two cans to
mine Irish balls I think the reason I
like this one number one it tastes
really good but I like chunky tuna like
I don't like when it's like mushy and
disgusting so I try to keep it quite
chunky and I feel like it just tastes
better you guys I'm just so easily
pleased
a rainbow tuna salad is like one of my
favorite lunches of all time I love it I
love how excited she is about her lunch
too and that's really how it should be
but I just appreciate that her meals
feel like really accessible and they
take kitchen shortcuts like bagged
spinach and canned tuna all of these
kind of kitchen staples are so great and
that is like a really satisfying lunch
that is probably very in expense
to put together as well so well done
okay sisters I'm just gonna be
completely real with you it's like I get
taken over by the sugar monster as soon
as it hits the 3 o clock it tastes
naughty but it's actually really healthy
for you so I'm just adding a little bit
of my deluxe mixer my food a nut mix and
then I'm obsessed with these chocolate
bikinis by loving earth they honestly
taste like a chocolate Coco Pops oh it's
so yummy and when I add the almond milk
like when you mix it together the milk
goes chocolaty and sweet from all the
dried fruit and it could count oh it's
so good that does look good I love when
like chocolate East Ariel makes milk
chocolaty that is that is the best and I
also totally agree on the 3 p.m. snack
attack situation I also love a little
some sweet to get me through that last
leg of the day but I don't like calling
things naughty just as something to just
an FYI but I would say that that granola
looks really awesome it's a great way to
pair fats and carbohydrates and fiber
and protein together which of course is
really good and yes a lot of griddles
out there are really high in
carbohydrates and sugar but pairing it
with some kind of seeds or nuts
definitely does help to slow down the
the blood sugar response because you're
getting that fiber and that fat and that
protein in there
also your products look really really
tasty so I would love to try them
someday if I'm in Australia I'm gonna
totally get try to hit you up lately
I've been loving all of my plant-based
meals and today I was craving a burger
you can eat a really healthy diet in a
maintainable and enjoyable way okay
these burger patties they were so
delicious and they turned
really well however they weren't perfect
so in the description bar below I am
going to make some comments that I think
you guys should do if you make them at
home just lift up some bikinis and
created buckwheat flour you can honestly
use any kind of flower you want
throughout this recipe I wish I didn't
have to use a nutribullet if you have a
food processor I would highly recommend
using that because in my nutribullet
I had to use so much water okay I don't
know what I'm doing here because I end
up putting it in the nutribullet anyway
so this was done okay so as you can see
this was like a constant battle for me
to try to get the right consistency like
I said I just have to add way too much
water into my nutribullet to get it to
mix properly so I had to add so much
buckwheat flour actually all of it and
then you can see here that I tried to
add some almond flour right out of that
as well we've all been there when like
recipes don't quite work out so I really
love that Sara is super transparent
about that and she offers lots of great
suggestions and substitutions and she's
all just felt like freestyling in the
kitchen and using up what you already
have in the fridge which to me is just
really real that's how most of us cook
we don't always follow a recipe we don't
always have the best perfect recipe come
out you know perfectly every single time
I certainly don't so I appreciate that
sara is like totally talking about it
and also this looks really good it's a
great idea I love being a good burger
I love veggie burgers I love regular
burgers I love all burgers I don't
discriminate but it really is all about
how you build it and I say Sara you did
you did good so all of my favorite
ingredients we've got the healthy fats
from the avocado and the tahini you've
got tons of antioxidants and fiber from
all these great veggies this looks
amazing and I mean it's like got
everything that you want in one bite I
love that every single
and lately I've been loving the salted
caramel block of chocolate by loving
earth but tonight I just wanted
something a little bit more hearty a
little bit more filling so I went for
the chocolate coated almonds and these I
love sweet too I also have a sweet tooth
and I can't lie I love chocolate covered
almond so great easy store-bought you
don't need to always like make
everything from scratch
and while chocolate and its own right is
amazing and great if you want to make a
little more satisfying pairing it with
some kind of nut is a great way to do
that because it's adding that fiber
protein and healthy fats so it
definitely is my kind of bedtime snack
so let's take a look at Sara's day in
general and give you some basic overall
notes so from a macronutrient
distribution based on our calculations
Sara's getting about 45 percent of her
calories from carbohydrates 35 percent
from fat and 20 percent from protein so
of course very balanced very beautiful
lots of color lots of fiber protein
healthy fats it's great I'm loving it
Bravo so here's what I like about Sara's
diet basically her diet is very flexible
and balanced her diet seems very kind of
consistent and regular with three meals
a day plus snacks she also talks about
her pre and post-workout snack which I
think is really helpful for those of us
who are into fitness because this
undoubtedly will help with athletic
performance also doesn't seem to follow
any really strange rules and really is
just eating what works best for her I
know that she was vegan for a specific
timeframe but nowadays she seems to
follow a more flexible plant-based foods
but of course still incorporating in
some you know fish and other ingredients
when it feels good for her so I think
that is really great number two her
meals feel pretty easy and approachable
so I like that most per meals are really
simple they are made up of pretty
accessible ingredients with the
exception of course of the supplements
but for the most part she kind of just
cooks what she feels like she cooks what
she has in the fridge in the pantry she
free styles she also offers a lot of
great tips and tricks for substitutions
or meal prep or little meal hacks as she
calls them so I think that her channel
does offer a lot of good meat so to
speak or a lot of good information for
the viewers who are watching her number
three Sara doesn't make any outrageous
nutrition claims so with the exception
of the whole lemon water flushing toxins
thing which it kind of does but not any
better than regular water Sara doesn't
make any claims that her diet will you
know lead to weight loss or cure knee
illnesses
she really just seems to be eating in a
way that works well for her and I think
that's really great
and finally Sara seems to eat a pretty
well varied diet for this genre in the
health influencer space she seems to be
like a genuine foodie who just like
likes to try out new foods or
ingredients or recipes and always is
experimenting I like that she just kind
of throws in like chia seeds and her
smoothie or hemp parts in her lunch it's
a great easy way to kind of boost the
nutrition content with fiber in protein
healthy fats these are things that I do
a lot as well because they're just like
really simple moves that you can make to
make a big impact so I think that's
great
the only concern I have with Sara's
channel in this video is that there
still is a pretty strong clean eating
rhetoric going on which is not
compatible with the intuitive eating
model so it is absolutely not that I'm
saying that Sara's diet is too healthy
she seems to legitimately just be eating
in a way that really serves her in her
body well which is great it just happens
to be super nourishing so that's awesome
however it really comes down to the
language used here and I did hear a lot
of kind of good bad when she was talking
about not drinking enough water or Nadi
when she was talking about her dessert
and I just think that that is all
language that comes from diet culture
and die culture can be so heavily
ingrained in us starting as young as
just you know preschool and we're little
little girls so it's very hard to
unlearn some of this behavior and
language but I do think it is a really
important thing to pursue because it is
the first step in terms of embracing
intuitive eating so guys I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did be sure to
give it a thumbs up lean
comment below some other youtubers that
you want me to review subscribe to the
channel and do not forget to watch the
entire playlist with some more great
what a tin add a material and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye